[Music]
thank you
right now I think that Dimitri is more
focused on the result than ig6 mate oh
gosh can you play Brooks
no hesitation yep that fork ends the
game
we have the winner of our inaugural RCC
season
unbelievable and I think that was some
Applause there for edema Jan it seems
like you like being interviewed by me
and Daniel because you keep winning
events
yeah then you know that was my goal to
speak to two guys missed you a lot
yeah this is
[Applause]
I'm screaming on her behalf
foreign
but you can't pre-move in those
situations
oh my goodness oh no and it's still
might be a draw
okay okay I'm getting up for you oh D3
goodbye okay so oh I didn't realize that
you can't put A8 thanks Rook D2 or Rook
B2 and then you just take the pawn on B4
oh king of six Rook before Bishop E7
only chance if you go for six people
with Bishop E7 but then Rook B8 and then
that gives up an exchange and he's got
chances
Bishop B7 there's chances take E7
oh my gosh oh my gosh that didn't just
happen
oh
oh my god I've never seen anything like
this in my life
oh and he's he is just destroyed
emotionally right now oh my God
how
what in the world I didn't even see the
mate me neither I'm going to dictate the
fate of the world title meanwhile the
white rook's harassing this black queen
Lawrence where's this black queen going
five seconds
this is just oh this is a bloodbath this
should be a win now for Magnus Carlson
three seconds to have two story made
that move with one second left all
Magnus needs to do now is consolidate
protect all his pieces curl up into a
ball and ensure there are no last minute
tricks white has an extra night that
will decide the game and uh tour of down
to one second for the third move in a
row walking into a fork but Magnus has
seen it all grabbing two pawns and a
handshake it's confirmed Magnus Carlson
gets the double he wins the world Blitz
Championship Lawrence
wow Magnus Carlson I said it before the
round when the Fate is in his hands
what a spot with white in the last round
he tends not to fail Magnus Carlsen
triple world champion classical rapid
and Blitz Niha has his back against the
wall if you have to play Bishop H2 oh my
God Levy at that point H6 played he's
like replacing the business nobody can
just take it and the Knight defense G7
and you can't take the Knight because
the Rook takes on D1 with check G takes
F4 wins the game for Wesley yep all he
takes the four is over but this we might
be looking at the final moves of the
chess.com Global Championship right here
there we go nihal with the final Bluff
Wesley does not buy it g takes F4 and
the last gasps zero compensation on the
next move he's taking that night off the
board immediately get out of there nihal
grabs his head oh my God that's it and
that's it that's it ladies and gentlemen
the headphones are taken off for the
last time all smiles as Wesley takes the
first cgc title and the 200th thousand
dollar first prize Levy what a moment
what a moment indeed Wesley so we see
they're holding the 24 Karat 50-pound
trophy that may or may not be accurate
massive congratulations to him he has
been lights out the past two matches I
like that man I like everybody everybody
huge shout out first and foremost to the
city of Toronto and all the fans they
have showed up daily to remind me how
much I screwed up to not have live
ticket sales for this event but so many
of them are with us now and we we gave
them the special treat of doing so but
all right Wesley we got to get gotta get
to you man you did it yeah I'm very
happy we've won the global Chess
Championship
no oh Magnus fluttered he had H3
what's going on four seconds for Magnus
two three seconds two seconds he goes
before first and whoa he's gonna play A4
oh my gosh he's got trousers but so does
go cash G7 G7 white who's winning
White's winning it's made for white
where's the mate though I don't know but
it's gotta be there oh my God
oh my gosh
oh no see what you're saying yes E3 so
Hikaru look at garvin's face
the car was like really really Riley oh
my goodness Carl looks disgusted at the
opening and he doesn't I don't think he
thinks it's a mouse lip does he no I
mean if it was a mouse that we'd see it
reflected on duda's face one
what
wait
what is going on did he just
he playing a bomb cloud
I'm speechless I'm usually not
speechless I always know what to say
I don't know what I'm supposed to say
right now what am I what are we supposed
to say right now I just we don't see the
chat Cham is being nuts right here
absolutely oh my goodness I'm so used to
having a chat on the screen somewhere
when I'm live casting I knew something
was up when he played E3 I could sense
it
you just you saw the decision made in
that critical moment instead of going
for the draw
and hikara just went there and just
shook his head immediately yeah just
shook his head he's just like oh man
this is this is falling apart
Rich report did his best but his best to
beat Jana Palms who has lost zero games
in this candidates I guess it's just not
enough for any player in the field and
Jan I wonder if finally Express himself
because he's been so calm so collected
trying so hard not to let his emotions
betray him will we see a smile oh and
there it is the clocks are stopped the
2022 fide candidates are won by Yan
Napoli a respectful smile and there we
see it finally allows up to him yeah you
could see him breathing for the first
time in like two weeks and he must be
ecstatic
excuse me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God he plundered Queen A8
he blundered Queen A8
how is that even possible I mean how do
you blunder just a piece just like that
how do you blunder Queen A8 and he's
he's there and and nepo's like well what
do you want from me I I think my boy
just what why did you give me a point
here I don't get it
what wow absolutely
insane stuff
so there's something first result
an interest interestingly what we now
have are to us is we have the reverse of
the first and now Wesley so has to win
game two
extraordinary
some total brain lag I mean I don't
understand it but I'm I don't understand
what the Arbiters are doing there
clarification on that a bit later on
very strange very strange moment because
I mean this entire sequence it just
just makes no sense right all right
thank you so much and good luck for
tomorrow
riding thanks so much that was a tough
game and uh see you soon
aim and see you soon
really slowly right now yeah don't sleep
on Joshua speed he's gonna pre-move
everything here he's going to prove
every move now but can do both check
made him off the street it's not over
just yet but you're right you're not
saving up what you said last time don't
go for checkmate don't go for checkmate
just just do quick moves very close yeah
but he's very slow he's very very slow
it's awesome removing everything once
again is out of four seconds is he gonna
make it in time I don't think so another
king walks out Bishops yeah
oh my goodness
he finally got the right configuration
and with 0.4 seconds remaining the Neil
dubov he's able to win that game
see through Sicilian is Vortex bullet
weapon he plays the same openings that
he does in Blitz and classical which I
think is a great strategy because you
know them better
but why does he keep spending so much
what's he doing where'd he go he's just
stretching he's like is he doing yoga in
a bullet game
he's smiling while I was doing it Eric
why did Eric take all that time too
I have no idea do they think it's a
classical tournament or something
and Eric blundering upon in exactly the
same way oh this is there was a a kid
walked on
on stream probably bortnick's kid yeah
that's I know poor thing as a kid he's
like I'm playing I'm busy sorry go away
but one day you'll understand because
good pre-moving but don't stalemate this
is stalemate Central oh stupid oh no
oh my God I'm sorry my fault
Bobby disgusted just threw something
there
I didn't catch that it's got 40 more
seconds
Rookie's losing he's lost his position
does he have enough time oh my gosh
Magnus has to show off the mouse speed
right now because this is a winning
position for white he is winning a
second Pawn just like a car did in a
previous game
Magnus cannot afford to waste a single
second this could be over if Hikaru can
bleed another minute off the batch clock
here we go one minute 10 seconds every
second counts King H6 he's gonna win G5
G5 okay G7 seven it's winning oh my God
no but Hikaru he has 15 more seconds he
needs to bleed 15 seconds can you get
fate move if you're Magnus your car is
gonna make it happen
he wins the speech Chess Championship
Magnus gives a little bit clap forehead
car Nakamura but what a performance from
the American Superstar he has won the
Fisher random World Championship this
year he's winning title Tuesday pretty
much twice every single Tuesday and now
he has taken the speed Chess
Championship that is your streamer that
is your SCC winner 2022. if you see
Hikaru touch the beep on the Fisher
random World Championship will be over
Hikaru is one move away from 65 000
additional dollars as well as the title
and he's taking all of the time he needs
to take he doesn't play before he plays
Rook D7 but now he plays it it will lead
to Checkmate because if the kid goes up
to C4 you have Rook H5 swinging to C5
with mate if the King goes back to B6 is
Rook B7 Rook takes A7 and the other Rook
comes here it is Rook H5 on the board
Hikaru Nakamura wins the Fisher random
World Championship what a performance
from him he lost game three in the match
game four was a draw off for agreed to
and Jana pump she gave all he could
handle but when it all is said and done
Hikaru Nakamura stands the top of the
world and fish are random
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]